hey guys welcome back to new rockstars
my name is Sam bash and today I'm here
to talk about the newly released trailer
for Marvel and Netflix's newest series
the defenders we've been waiting three
years since this idea the show was
announced and with this trailer my
concerns are starting to fade away at
the very least we'll get some kick-ass
action scenes with daredevil Jessica
Jones and Luke Cage and probably iron
fist hop right into breaking down this
trailer here's a spoiler warning for the
defenders and all of marble Netflix's
shows roll the clip
the thing about war is it only works as
both sides believe they're the good guys
the truth is were not so different we
fight to get back what was once ours
right other gates we see calling wing
and Danny wind exiting a helicopter my
guess is it's defender series takes
place only a few weeks or a few months
after the conclusion of iron fist during
the finale of iron fist we find out that
Kunlun has banished whole damn city just
pooped off the world in the comics
Kunlun technically exists on another
plane of existence and a portal between
earth and cologne opens every few years
so my guess is the colon is probably
just trapped in another dimension
somewhere and Danny doesn't know where
to look for them not surprising he
doesn't know anything my point here is
that Danny and Colleen now a couple have
probably been searching for leaves to
wear : could be best way to find out
investigate your enemies meaning the
hand maybe Danny and Colleen have been
overseas hunting down members of the
hand and something turns their attention
to New York which makes sense based on
the handed training facility that we
learned about in iron fist season 1 not
really sure why neither Danny or Colleen
thought about that but hey we've learned
thus far that Danny isn't the smartest
dude anyways this might be the moment
when they return to the Big Apple now
what is that giant crack in the earth
that's racing towards them is this the
MCU mole man finally making his attack
yeah that'll never happen especially in
these shows I mean we can't even get a
dragon in the MCU we're definitely not
going to be getting this giant secret
underground civilization no matter how
cool that might be I do have a real
theory about this though remember that
enormous hole in the ground that
daredevil discovered in season 2 the one
that the hand had been digging we never
really revisited that plotline I got
wrapped up in Elektra is the dark
whatever that means whatever the hand
insta Gordon Weaver have planned it
probably involves that whole maybe we're
going to see the return of some MCU tech
as the culprit of this micro earthquake
we've seen hammer Tech's make an
appearance in this series and we know
that ran enterprises has been
infiltrated by the hand in the past so
what if grant enterprises has been
secretly developing a doomsday weapon
and Danny is none the wiser possibly
next week you see a hospital on fire but
I want to come back to that in just a
second I think it's evidence of a bigger
plot point and maybe an opportunity to
get even more side characters from these
shows to make an appearance in the
defenders next we see Jessica Jones
looking anxious possibly trying to shake
a tail the Edit suggests that it's Matt
Murdock but my gut says it's either two
different scenes edited together I do
think that jessica is being tailed by
possibly the hand or maybe someone she's
been investigating maybe she's been
tailing someone who has ties to the hand
she got in too deep and now people are
after her now that's true I think that's
how we get Matt and Jessica's first
meeting but when we saw in the first
teaser for the show where Jessica is
being interrogated by misty 9 maybe
Jessica witnesses something truly
heinous or maybe she's caught
investigating a crime scene right when
the police show up
so she's hauled in for questioning a
little does she know the handed knew she
was coming and framed her to get her out
of the way now here's where things get
interesting and I think I know how this
leads to our defenders coming together
for the first time but I'll come back to
that in just a second don't want to get
too confusing our next shot is of Luke
Cage stepping off of a bus presumably in
Harlem a little research we found out
that the six one three plus the one he
is on does go from Grand Central Station
to Harlem in the morning so that's
basically confirmed also from a creative
standpoint the yellowish hue in this
scene is reminiscent of luke cage's solo
series keep an eye out for color schemes
that's all I'm saying
iron fist first scene with green Jessica
Jones had a purplish hue to it now Luke
eight is yellow seems like the
individual shows color schemes are
seeping into the series the fun tidbit
but wait a minute
Luke is in Harlem lastly some he's been
taken away to seek a prison down in
Georgia well it looks like you got out
yet again and he's looking pretty happy
probably didn't break out of prison
again so maybe he had some help sure I
would have loved it if the other three
have took a road trip down to Georgia to
break him out of jail
but I guess we should just try to button
up this whole prison storyline pretty
quick
my guess Luke got some legal help either
from mr. daredevil or more possibly from
Hogarth firm I merely want this because
I want Luke's first encounter with some
of Daredevils cast to be foggy please
and thank you probably we don't have to
spend too much time in this season
dealing with Luke getting out of prison
just get that dude out and up to New
York save the day but bring you
background again I think one of the
first people Luke is going to catch up
with when he gets back to New York is
misty Knight here's my train of thought
Luke ones into the police station to see
misty and chicken on Harlem misty is
exiting the interrogation room with Matt
Murdock and Jessica Jones his former
lover Luke and Jessica are now seeing
each other for the first time in a long
time
their first meeting will probably be
cordial but maybe Jessica mentions her
case and Luke uses his pole with Missy
to get some info unaware of Jessica's
perp could be since the police stations
work in TV shows the three of them and
then head off together to the business
complex where they run into Danny ran
getting pummeled by these suits but I'm
getting ahead of myself last thing I
want to point out Sigourney Weaver's
characters narration only named
Alexandra is fairly interesting based on
her mention of war it seems like we're
finally coming to the end of the hands
storyline in these shows let's be honest
we know the defenders are probably going
to win and the hand is going down but
I'm interested to see how the hand
handles war as Alexander called it sure
an earthquake is a threatening
instigator but why now what's the end
goal they try to do the classic rule all
the land story chokes they top all the
buildings in New York and then rebuild
everything and call it a new hancher it
isn't the worst idea I guess we'll have
to wait and see
Pennsylvania this is Dawson anyways roll
the next clip
but in the end and this is the end it's
just a city you'll get used to watching
them fall and here's a slight
confirmation to my theory the gang shows
up takes out that hand and they retreat
now my guess is that Danny is now
checking in on his business seeing how
it's going making sure that none of the
hand has infiltrated his organization
damn it
full community organization again my
guess is that when Alexandra's narration
says if they're taking back what is ours
it's referring to Rand enterprises
danny is not happy an attempt to take
his company back by force we always know
that never works that never works Danny
damn it awesome moment where we get the
whole team taking on the hand in suits
can't have a Netflix series without a
hallway fight scene but who's that woman
in the red outfit in the background
dumb question we already know it's
probably Elektra but based on the shock
and the following shots of Elektra in
the hoodie on the rooftop with Alexandra
she's not the same Elektra we saw in
season two a daredevil after she was
murdered by the hand and then put into
that vat of blood and magic I'm guessing
we've got a little resurrection on our
hands but maybe the hand has found a way
to rewire her brain to do their bidding
maybe a little amnesia she's not looking
all there in her eyes my guess
Alexander is using Elektra as a weapon
flash distraction to keep the defenders
preoccupied as the hand move forward
with their plan also I think we may be
getting a hint to where someone went
Alexander says that you'll get used to
watching cities burn did the hand
actually destroy Kunlun maybe but maybe
not I'm gonna stick with my theory that
they moved the city but from the hands
point of view they believe they've
destroyed come on forever
either way Matt looks great in Jessica's
scarf makes me kind of miss Frank
Miller's inspired design of his costume
in season one anyways next play
thank respect for now we need to figure
out our next vote so there's no next
move and there is no we
what is that we're not here to eat those
pork Nona shrimp oh this guy's got pork
daddy Raritan I'm not looking for Super
Friends fat Easter Egg time
notice how the Marvel logo hasn't
updated to the new Marvel studio logo we
saw in Doctor Strange and spider-man I
feel like it's assigned to us the Marvel
TV branch is more separated from the
movie branch than we originally thought
yes we all want daredevil to punch Iron
Man right in the face but that's
probably not going to happen at least
not in the upcoming infinity war movie
and probably all other future Marvel
movies I don't know maybe I'm being too
pessimistic I mean an after credit scene
was confirmed by Marvel TVs head
Jeff blow and maybe it could be Tony
Stark asking him to come fight a giant
purple aliens now it's probably Punisher
but uh I don't know I kind of wanted to
be Iron Man anyways we next get
hopefully what becomes the headquarters
of the defenders the Royal dragon
honestly they don't seem like a team
that would need a secret hideout but up
waking dreams but based on Jessica
busting Maps balls about his powers
maybe she'll have some fun with Danny on
his Dragon Tattoo because they're in the
Royal dragon dragon tattoo there's
obviously a joke there I'm basing
writing the damn series all by myself
plus tax we have just gotten our first
nod from Marvel to DC Comics do you
remember how Luke refers to this group
that's right super friend the same name
of the hanna-barbera cartoon that starts
Superman Batman Wonder Woman Emma Boyd
the flash I guess that this is the
closest we'll ever get to a crossover so
enjoy it
we then see daredevil in his costume
taking on a man with a pipe I believe so
I guess the whole giving up being
daredevil conclusion we got to in
daredevil season 2 didn't really take I
mean of course it would because that
would have made this a really weird
season other defenders if he wasn't in
costume that's not all that I noticed in
the scene though notice what cinder
blocks my guess is that daredevil is
following up on the previously mentioned
hole he discovered in season 2 hopefully
he's got some backup
the next thing with Danny and Luke
should make fans very happy this seems
like a clear nods to the Heroes for Hire
team of Power Man and Iron Fist their
alter egos in the comics
look into any startup business where
people
can literally hire superheroes to come
solve their problems with Heroes for
Hire show be a good idea yeah - to
replace Iron Fist season - wouldn't mind
it and Jessica scene is the perfect
depiction of how she probably feels
about this team up and how effective
she'd be in battle sure she's got super
powers but she clearly doesn't want to
be a hero
also I'm glad we've got some humor in
this series I miss Jessica okay much
next clip please that doesn't matter
can't fight these people not even with
whatever it is your hand can do it's
cheap it's not they're hunting up
friends our families and I'm not going
to stop there
and here's the confirmation that Electra
wasn't that hallway during our first
epic team-up nice if she's wearing red
would you look at that she's checking
out her signature weapon from the comics
that's right
those are scythe fun fact there's this
long-running fan theory that sometimes
is explored in the comics with the ninja
turtle and daredevil have intertwined
origins like the same news that mutated
the turtles took away meant eyesight and
gave them his powers but another thing I
noticed guess which weapon the red
turtle Raffaele uses that's right sighs
with two red guys used times pretty cute
also oops hand brainwashing definitely
confirmed after Elektra murders just all
those individuals that she's training
with we knew she had a more violent
streak in daredevil but this is a whole
nother level of intensity however what
if there's more to the scene what if
she's acting out because the real
Elektra is hidden away deep inside
maybe she's fighting to get out and that
act of her killing those men is proof
that she isn't the perfect soldier the
hand thought they had created pure
biting into the season she'll probably
be back to some form of herself from
season two of daredevil kind of like to
use a Buffy at the end of Winter Soldier
but anyways I'm excited to see how we
work up to that point also I love how
each of the defenders are making fun of
each other daredevil doesn't get Danny's
deal and neither does Jessica it seems
like but you recognize who Danny is
fighting in the Stuart that cloak looks
awfully familiar I'm guessing that
Elektra who's either been cornered by
Danny or she's hunting him down should
be interesting hope Danny doesn't punch
a hole straight through a damn chest
because in the first season we saw him
punch a hole through a brick building
I'm pretty sure that's enough power to
punch someone sternum through the back
we also hear Danny say that the hand is
hunting down their friends and family
which brings us back to the hospital on
fire in the beanie of the trailer I'm
guessing the hand went hunting for
Claire temple aka the night nurse aka
friends of all these heroes at her place
of work the hospital we also see her
cornered later with calling wing by none
other than the Kudo member of the hand
we last saw him getting pretty messed up
by Colleen in season one of iron fist so
he's probably not too happy to see those
two don't kill em please the next
sequence just makes me so happy because
not only are we think Karin in this
season not only we sing Trish in this
season or definitely think foggy and he
finally fixed his hair from daredevil he
looks so much better he looks like a
real attorney
but anyway we see Trish's car stuck in a
ditch is this the hand trying to get at
her or is this a result of the
earthquake in Manhattan it's probably
the latter but still cool and the final
shot of the scene is of what I assume to
be a member of the hand falling through
a skylight of the Royal dragon
restaurant looks like he's a little late
in the defenders have faked here at the
restaurant maybe or have a we'll find
out soon next clip more gases coming we
only can keep in Manhattan for Kremlin
to a pile of dust just the four of you
war is definitely coming to New York
let's hope Luke Cage can stop all those
bullets and those guns they look like
serious business
but never fear dick is back he's here to
drop a crap ton of exposition on the
heads of our crime fighters we then get
the ground literally rippling from what
I can guess to be the same for a play
from the beginning of the trailer that's
no normal earthquake not that the
earthquakes in New Yorkers are normal
but the cars are lifting off the ground
you should be afraid one compliment I
want to give to the showrunners which I
mentioned before but I just love that we
get to see the characters color schemes
and the lighting design of the show
Maxon red Jessica's and purple Luke is
saving a woman in yellow respect I like
it next we get Madame Gao popping up and
looking to be in a staredown with
Alexandra my guest is go is reporting to
Alexandra being a member of the hand but
based on their looks that probably I'm
insane change with Gao somewhat
assisting two defenders in one way or
another across all shows I have a
feeling that she'll have some sort of
change apart by the end of this 8
episode series or maybe not maybe she'll
just stab Alexandra in the back and take
all the power for herself and it seems
like guy would do that at the very least
please explain a little bit more what
girl's abilities are we know she's got
skills but come on makes forget stick
talking to the team with most of them in
their costumes but not so much Danny but
everyone else looks almost comic
accurate pretty cool now where is this
speeder
maybe the Opera House could be another
option for a hideout for the team but
possibly this is just the headquarters
for the chase the group that stick
leaves now if you don't know the chase
is another group that is not usually
associated with kun LUN that works to
fight the hand so we've got the handing
attack on two fronts will that be enough
who knows
with the wars are New York and Topher
not yet
I hear reforms this shot of Elektra in
her black outfit on a route holding
swords why do you think she'd been
tasked to do I'm getting the feeling
that the hand knows that Matt Murdock is
daredevil and to try to take him down
when he least expects it they're going
to send his thought to be dead love her
to his place of work a police station to
take him out or maybe she's just fine
but spies don't usually walk around with
giant swords in their hands now do they
we then see stick in custody of
Alexandra I have some theories as to how
freakin stick could get captured one the
hand attack the chase unexpectedly
instinct was overwhelmed by all the
soldiers or to stick in the chase
attempted to take on the hand with a
lecture up on the side of the devil's
dick faltered and could attack his own
daughter of sorts either way this might
be the end of stick to the Netflix
series I love them but he's just
important enough to be killed to
motivate the superheroes got to always
have that sacrifice the next shot is the
money shot we finally get all the heroes
and their costumes all staying together
ready to fight we can often take down by
each of the defenders even one of the
members of the hanging chefs through a
support beam wait a minute a support
beam and what looks to be an underground
mind could this possibly be in the hole
previously mentioned near the endgame
probably had something to do with that
damn hole what could the hand be doing
down there maybe something's hidden down
there or maybe they're placing a weapon
down there below new york we shall see
don't get too excited about the
defenders kicking all the ass because
Elektra is clearly down there and
fighting Iron Fist I'm feeling like a
lecturer is he going to be turned back
to our normal stuff until maybe Airy end
the season or will be explored in
daredevil season three maybe all the
great team of Jessica and daredevil
great joke about the horns also love the
color scheme of this restaurant flash
bar red and purple lights you have
daredevil standing in the red and
Jessica standing in the purple
little touches like this makes the show
so special role next quickly
I can see you've formed a kind of pond I
promise you with temporary
Oh huh they will disappoint you Jessica
like it or not you belong out there
together
say an iron Fez doing a flip off the
roof getting ready for battle
obviously the Power Rangers taught us
that backflips always lead to awesome
fight but don't miss that color scheme
green and yellow now is he chasing that
woman in the next shot my money's on no
but probably Jessica Jones like to
probably couldn't crush a collar with
her feet but who is she running from too
early to call this trailer does do a
solid job of showing the team working as
just that a team not just with the epic
side shots of the defenders Plus Nick
but also with Luke Cage and Jessica
Jones using that huge pipe to not have
some bad guys don't celebrate too
quickly because like normal people
superheroes hold grudges especially when
you kind of killed someone significant
other you Jessica and Luke actually I'm
surprised that when be working out this
interpersonal conflict in only eight
episodes but hey every superhero team
needs some sort of drama I'm like 20
feet we even get this argument hinted at
by Alexandra when she tries to get into
the team's heads and tear them down see
you formed a kind of on I promise you
this temper that also notice where
they're standing all back-to-back the
Royal dragon maybe should have ran
further away from where that hallway
fight scene took place but hey I'll try
not to judge
back to drama' for a second time unless
Jess on the hive thanks Matt now all the
frontal they seem to be in the same
hallway where the fight takes place or
maybe there's an exterior shot of the
building where the hallway fighting
takes place
I don't know both are good ideas thank
you Sam you're welcome
we also see someone comforting Elektra
in the next scene and I'm guessing it's
daredevil based on his love if I may
make one request for this season don't
kill off a lecturer please she's a fun
character for Matt to work with and I
just don't need him carrying around that
guilt in season 3 of daredevil I know
all heroes on TV are moody but let's
have him be moody about something else
please well to get daredevil an iron
fist fighting which is awesome who's the
better fighter
the man trained in Kunlun or the man
trained by the legendary stick can't
call it now but do pay attention to the
location look familiar
it's the same abandoned theater or Opera
House which to Eve than the four one one
on their enemy if that just happened
then why are they fighting aren't
daredevil and iron fists on the same
side when it comes to the hand here's my
final list theory might have a few more
by the end of this trailer but if the
hand can brainwash Elektra what's
stopping them from brain
one of the defenders to take on the rest
of them some of you might say that
Elektra is more easily brainwashed
because she was just resurrected I get
it that makes sense
story wise but if you really want to
tear this team apart then you'd send one
of their own after them but maybe two
zombie ninjas is just too too many for
this series also we just appreciate
daredevil costume for a second we got a
shot of him kneeling in the mud spitting
up blood and also probably teeth but the
whole ensemble just really works
personally just kind of took me a while
to appreciate the horns and such but now
I'm 100% on board I didn't want to throw
one idea at you about this theme though
what if this scene is more than just
daredevil throne of blood what if it's a
nod to mass fate in the comics keeps a
devout Catholic and you do get some of
that in this show
maybe we'll see Matt reconnecting with
his faith throughout the season maybe he
has doubts about such a huge threat
looming overhead that he consults with
the church and we get more scenes with
that preached in season 1 and 2 of
daredevil I miss that guy next we see a
lecture in what looks to be the Royal
dragon restaurant so it's fair to say
that the reveal to Matt probably already
happened probably before we have iron
fist he'll think daredevil up in that
hallway fight scene also gay iron grism
daredevil working together that's what
the show is all about we also get a shot
of an explosion destroying a building
and immediately I was worried that it
was pops barbershop based on the street
view not again don't go through that
pollute that's not fair you can only do
so much to one building but based on the
metal awning and design of the windows
on the building next door my guess is
probably just another view of the
hospital explosion that we saw earlier
not a better option but the hospital
theory is backed up when you declare
we're covering on the bumper of an
ambulance hopefully she didn't get
physically here and I hope Luke gets
there quick to support her or maybe he
can we see him holding a flaming pipe
could this be the catalyst for the
hospital explosion did the defenders
fail and did we just lose a hospital in
the process can't really tell based on
the setting but these shows are known
for being bold let's do the show owners
put these characters through hell let's
see they become better heroes by the NBC
final quickly
glad we found each other I'm not hugging
[Music]
down long week
hey I'm Jessica sneak-attack this
specific apartment complex doesn't look
familiar but I will never get tired of
seeing her kick all of the ass even iron
fist gets a solid finishing move in that
came from earlier taking down like were
like eight dudes all at once but wait
holy [ __ ] I think we just found someone
who could defeat the iron fist
this shot right here look at who's
trying to block Danny's punch madam
pricking yeah we never really see her
exert any real stress during the fights
we've seen her in so far could she block
or redirect the iron fist or is this the
end of Madame Gao has Danny finally
become the immortal iron fist that he
kept bragging about I don't know we'll
have to wait and see this last shot
before the defenders logo and come as
you are plays it's gold by the way we
can probably say that this is the theme
song for the group to come as you are
meaning that these super people probably
aren't the ideal superheroes but hey
you're still going to save the day
anyway they're devil is proud of what
they're doing and Luke shoots them down
frog I'm not hugging you just kidding
hug man come on Luke I'm guessing we'll
see a hug the end of the season but dang
it it better be a good one
maybe Captain America can join in now
I'm just asking too much aren't I
maybe Punisher you know because he's
been teased a lot but he doesn't seem as
bad you type the final Chatham show
Jessica drinking in public checking a
beer on the subway getting judgmental
looks from her teammate the last thing I
want to point out and this does not make
just look too good did she just steal a
beer from a homeless man there's a man
passed out on the subway beer in his
hand but the back of the ear found
before the subway I don't know maybe I'm
being too judgmental let's just hope
that maybe Jessica block the beers and
she gave the rest away to this man and
I'm gonna get to know she probably just
took one right on the bag but on that
note what do you think of this defenders
trailer with a show this monumental my
guess is that we'll get
some teases for future Marvel Netflix
shows and possibly some hints to maybe
crossovers with ABC for the movies
hopefully which do you think will get
let us know in the comments down below
for those of you who are looking for a
kick-ass new show to watch while you
wait for the defenders why not check out
verse made by the team over at quench
your old verb is home to your favorite
channels they give you a chance to
discover more content from the craters
you know and love and support their new
stuff if you're a fan of the creators of
Adventure Time then you've got to start
watching the cartoon of hangover Channel
they've got bee and puppycat and trust
me it's worth checking out if you're
more of an anime fan then go ahead and
check out the Funimation channel where
you can watch attack on Titan C into dub
but if you're more of a fan of subtitles
then go ahead and check out crunchyroll
channel they've got options for
everybody check it out for yourselves
their library of content is always
expanding to make it even easier for you
go to WWF Co slash go premium and sign
up for a free 7-day trial of the Verve
combo pack where you can watch all your
favorite anime like my hero Academy a
season 2 ad free nhg on all of your
devices go ahead and check out that link
or click the link in the description
below thank you all for watching please
give this video a like and if you've got
any comments or questions about this
video write them down below or hit me up
on Twitter I'm at Sam basher and I'll
see you guys next time